ce que j'ai voulu montrer c'est qu'avec
une simplicité naturelle
on est capable de se remonter en très
peu de temps et aussi à mieux marché que
cela soit à portée de tous c'est bon la
façon de préparer les mets la simplicité
que cela offre mais aussi toute
l'énergie pouvoir entrer plus d'un
moment on peut multiplier l'argentine
poutine et permettent que avec une telle
alimentation qu'on est dans un système
créatif c'est à dire qu'on peut traiter
ces hommes de pathologies avoir un
meilleur confort digestif et mieux se
porter ce livre propose des examens
pourquoi parce que j'ai annoncée dans le
premier livre un certain nombre
d'éléments c'est un de graines de la
priory mination fin de parler de tout
cela mais il me fallait prouver que cela
était possible et cela a dépassé mon
entendement en faisant des analyses
biologiques
cela m'a permis de voir que ça allait au
delà des valeurs énergétiques que j'ai
proposé dans mon premier livre vous avez
travaillé avec le pas évidemment c'était
c'est dean organise qui permet de tester
les produits pour avoir une vérification
convenable pour être sûr de se réaliser